[Musique]
à quelques jours du scrutin l'une des
dernières occasions pour la coalition
des partis de droite de séduire les
Italiens
sur scène l'ancien Premier ministre
conservateur sylview Berlusconi le chef
de la Ligue formation d'extrême droite
Matéo Salvini mais dans la foule
certains sont arrivés des heures
d'avance pour entendre l'autre membre de
la coalition
[Musique]
celle qui aspirent à devenir la première
femme à diriger le pays Georgia Meloni
dirigeante de Fratelli d’italia les
frères d'Italie
[Musique]
italienne
dirige un parti décrit comme post
fasciste
héritier des formations politiques qui
ont suivi la deuxième guerre mondiale et
la chute de Benito Mussolini
pour lequel la politicienne ne cachait
pas son admiration dans ses débuts en
politique comme en témoigne ce reportage
réalisé il y a plus de 25 ans moi je
crois que
c'était un bon pollution c'est-à-dire
qui est tout ce qu'il a fait il a fait
pour l'Italie dont la formation arrive
en tête des intentions de vote tente de
prendre ses distances de cet héritage et
de polir son image une campagne menée
notamment ici en Italie mais aussi
ailleurs en Europe avec la publication
de vidéos en plusieurs langues dans le
français j'ai lu que la victoire de
fatalital et aux élections de septembre
conduiraient en deux astres en tournant
autoritaire à la sortie de l'Italie de
l'euro rien de tout cela n'est vrai il y
a un cadre de partie un militant de
partie qui a fait le salut romain donc
le sel fasciste a un funérailles donc en
plein Airton donc ça ça se voit s'ils
sont ils sont en difficulté à cacher ça
mais pour cette observateur de la vie
publique italienne le passé de Georgia
Meloni ne nuit pas nécessairement à
cette politicienne qui a fait son entrée
au Parlement en 2006
il faut dire aussi qu'elle a déjà
participé à un gouvernement donc ça
aussi ça montre quand même que on a déjà
banalisé le poste fascistes dans les
années 80 en 1994 sérieux Berlusconi il
fait un gouvernement avec les post
fascistes donc en fait c'est déjà
normalisé on n'est pas du tout dans une
nouveauté
Guy de creusetto ajustement fait partie
des gouvernements Berlusconi comme
sous-secrétaire à la défense avec
Georgia Meloni il est l'un des
co-fondateurs des frères d'Italie
est morte Mussolini et le fascisme sont
morts dit-il cet homme qui connaît très
bien George Meloni assure que les
différentes d'autres figures de la
droite radicale européenne comme Marine
Le Pen
en l'Alliance atlantique et elle est
impliquée dans l'Union européenne
en campagne Georgia Meloni a beaucoup
parlé d'inflation et d'énergie tout en
abordant des thèmes chers aux partisans
de l'extrême droite comme l'immigration
et la sécurité Queen dailmix
un mélange de radicalisme et d'une
expérience au sein des troubles de
mélodie à son avis la coalition de
droite sur un néfaste pour l'Italie et
l'Europe
sur les sanctions et la question
ukrainienne parce que si Mélanie s'est
montré critique la Russie c'est loin
d'être le cas de certains de ses
partenaires d'autres partis
les Italiens se prononceront bientôt
selon les sondages Georgia Meloni figure
de position depuis plusieurs années
pourrait bien gagner son Paris peu
importe les résultats la politicienne
ressort de cette campagne avec encore
plus de notoriété tout indique quel
contribuera à donner le rythme de la vie
politique italienne
ici rafale Bouvier au clair Radio-Canada
à Rome